Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier,
and welcome back to Subnautica...
Now I have already gone out and I got the crash powder
and I have the materials to MAKE the magnesium
I was very dumb in thinking I needed to get that,
I couldn't remember where and then I was like
"OH, YEAH, THAT'S UHH,
you make that from salt." So I've got enough
salt to do that, I've got the crash powder,
and weirdly enough, every time I went to one of those things
they kept blowing THEMSELVES up? Like, the pod and all, so
I had to go and find a whole bunch before I could find one that wasn't willing to
EXPLODE away all of it's crash powder-
But also before any of that, I've got three new lockers here
The first one is:
The Only Living Virus 1
Who said to "Spawn in Cutefish, please,
it's like your own pet and it follows you around."
Now I would do that, but unfortunately
I don't want to cheat.
So what I'm gonna have to do is that I'm gonna have to see if Cutefish is in the game in general
and then I'll have a little floaty companion (baby voice)
like bubblebutt!
...but that's going to be the name of my Sea Moth when I get that again.
And then there's GreyLabcoat22 that said
"What if the Sea Dragon is what destroyed the other pods,
or it destroyed the undewater base?" Now I don't know where the underwater base IS
Because I've only ever spawned there
[Inhale]
before through cheat codes.
But when I find it,
it's more likely that it was the Reaper Leviathan that destroyed the other pods.
Because
that's what's swimming around where I AM right now.
and able to kill ME and stuff.
so
[Nervous laugh]
And then, uh, then KnuckleBust10163 said:
What if on April Fools day, the Reaper...
[Dramatic Pause]
was a penis?
And ordinarily, that wouldn't make me laugh,
but we just played "Genital Jousting"
[Giggling] And I couldn't help but think
of the, the Reaper Leviathan as a
giant snake and dick, floatin' through the waters.
And that would be horrifying, more than it already is.
But either way, I ALSO I wanna reiterate. I do not have the diamond for the
laser cutter and this is a bit of a problem.
So the laser cutter needed a diamond as well  as everything else,
but unfortunately I think the diamond is down in like the purple area.
And I tried! I Tried to go down there I had my little glider, and I'm like
"Ima go down there, Ima gonna hit a couple
Outcrops and then come right back up."
(manly breath in)
Doesn't work, you die, I only get 75 seconds and below there.
(deep breath)
Air starts going away quickly, e, I even had my rebreather on and I tried it twice
And I died twice
It did (stutter) it just didn't work so
that's not gonna happen
for me.
So unfortunately that's just the way, that is so I need to put this stuff
awayyy. (itchy nose)
I'm going to make the magnesium
Habatabuski
HabataBUSKI
I'm gonna get out my titanium from LemonQueen
then I need the tools, I got the repair tool.
This is enough to do at least one thing on the Aurora
and I can't remember if that was the sea moth
(breath)
or if it was something else, but either way
I'm gonna go back there and try that because without
the sea moth. I don't think I can get the diamond, I can't
go down low enough.
I just don't have enough air, (markimoo swallows air)
the only other method with which to do that
would probably be to make pipes and a floating air pump.
Like literally that's the only way that I could possibly think
to get enough air to be able to do that.
And I might actually do that, considering right next to me
is the zang guard forest. (mumbles) I don't even know
if that's the name of it.
It's the big mushroom forest down below and there's
some cyclops fragment's down there. So that's my
other option for this episode.
When I went on the Aurora, I found a bunch of logs and
so there was just some general things talking about the
Aurora and the people on the Aurora
and how they were looking forward to going home finally.
And it's just bizarre because THERE is a bigger universe
being built in this game, and I'm not saying that's weird.
I'm saying I appreciate it but
it's interesting that its all, hidden in the environment
and is revealed through these logs.
Like you can see
all the wondrous technology that's around you
and you can see, the benefit of that
throughout everything you see in your survival.
In everything your crafting your able to make things
on demand, its able to rematerialize a block
of titanium into a floating air pump.
That's incredible technology
but also its interesting to see how this all
goes through
the environment and how you explore it
and how you see it
and how you live it
and how
everything around you is
effected by it.
So it it its just something interesting
in that I love environmental story telling.
It's a bit heavy handed because
its like, "Hey here some logs that tell you something."
but I like the cleverness in that,
it doesn't straight up tell you.
It tells you through the voices of the people
that of all DIED.
And there's been a lot of them on this big
honken ship.
You can rest assured
there's been a lot of people
that have died.
I just remembered there's only
one other thing that I have to do
before I do that.
I need to take these
mushrooms.
I need to take the copper
that I found and I need to make
a few more batteries because I am
literally
dead in the water for batteries,
and I do Not Have
(Sexy battery)
the plans necessary to build
the charging station
or at least I'm assuming
that's true.
I mean , maybe that's something
that I could actually build
and I should probably look before I make
any bold claims as to that.
Annnnnnndddd
DDDDDDDDDHHHHHH
YES that's absolutely true
I do not have, the stuff necessary
to be able to build
the battery recharger.
I'm not sure were that is but I'm pretty sure
that's probably gonna be on
one of the bases
but I don't know if I'm gonna be able to do THAT.
Because
I Don't HAVE
A Sea Moth
(lisp) to be able to explore things.
So
[Fake laugh] HAHAH AHAHA
I'm a bunch of Dead !
So were gonna get rid of the unnecessary things
we have
and then were all good to go.
Okay
Here we go
Were Going for it
YAY
Ah shit
(mumbles) god damn sharks
STAAAAAPPP [Loudly]
I don't waan any
GOOOO AWAAYY
I'll see you when I get back on the Aurora
because I can not remember
if the repair tool is everything that I needed
to be able to get, the Sea Moth.
I think I had to have the laser cutter but
if I do
then I gotta go with the Plan B
which is the air pumps
and I don't  wanna have to go through
Plan B.
Alright , so I gotta go through this infested bullshit
Mm So
Sea Moth Bay
IT DID, OH IT DID, IT DID
OOH IT DID
IT DID
It only needed repair tool
YEEESSS
YASSSSSSSSSSSSSSSSSSSS
OPEN SESAME!
Oh... Hello! OH, hello, mah baby!
OH, hello, mah baby! x2
OH, hello, mah baby! x3
Pressure compensator YEESSS PLEASEE
Oh no! Oh no! What happened to you! What happened to you my baby!
Oh no. Oh yes. Oh yes! Oh yes!
Okay so that, wait, that's, that's only two of three!
Where's the last one (x2)
Where is it? Huh? No! I was promised! No!
Well I don't know where the last Sea Moth piece is!
It's not down here because there's nothing left to repair.
Oh no wait there is but you know
I don't think it's going to be something super crucial to what I'm doing.
I guess I can repair all of this stuff because I might as well.
I have the repair tool, I can stop the radiation leakwidge
leakwidge (ha)
and then I should be able to do what I need to do
to be able to do
everything else.
Anyway its a good start
I have the pressure compensator which is something that
I didn't know that I was gonna be able to get down here.
So that's gonna automatically
allow me to go even deeper
and there were TWO Sea Moth fragments
down there.
(stammers)
I just would of thought there would of been
a third one, ready to go
but I guess I was wrong.
Mm Kay
Let's start with this one
got this one,
Haaaaaaaaa
Buski
Haaaaa
hhmmmmmm
Buski
kay, last one
and then all the radiation should be Gone.
Which means that I
Yeeeeeesss
Okay good
I mean I don't  know how that-
Aurora: -high energy particle containment field restored
auto decontamination sequence initiated.
Nice
Okay that answers that question-
Aurora: Radiation levels are estimated to return to safe levels
in T-minus
Days.
Nice .
Aurora: Ten hours
Nice okay so that's gonna do all that.
And that should help us
in regards to
Uhhh
being able to use a different suit when were around
the Aurora,
but that still doesn't solve my problem.
Their is an entire piece
of the Sea Moth
that's just missing and I don't know were it is.
I don't think its behind anything ,
I don't think like its burning in this wreckage over here.
I don't think there's anything below
that I can find,
I don't think there's another way in.
Like all of this has been closed off again
that's not a way in ,
that's not a way in,
yeah NOW this is just fully isolated.
Which is for the best, I mean it was pretty easy to get in here.
Its, its nice that it makes it a challenge
and you have to wait until it explodes
before you get in here.
And its not just a convenient passage
I don't know, its kind nice
like I appreciate it but
now I'm just kinda, awh man
I don't know where to go for the other Sea Moth piece.
Like I need a welding thing to be able to get through
here
and I just don't have that, for the Prawn.
Ahhh okay that's the Prawn Bay which is the mechanical suit
damn it I could of sworn that it was gonna give me another
Sea Moth piece.
Yeah either way that doesn't help us so we gotta keep
moving, you know it doesn't help just to continually flounder.
So we gotta keep going
at least the Aurora is repaired and at least we have
two pieces
and just one pressure compensator.
Which is all good
not worried about that at all
so this is gonna be okay
we will find it.
Okay, alright, so we've got to
I imagine there are places outside of the Aurora to find
the sea uh
the Sea Moth fragment's, I just don't know where
that's the only problem.
AAAAAAAAA I FORGOT THERE'S A LEVIATHAN RIGHT
Here.
Ee
Okay
Oh god I hate this
(mumbles) Where is he x2
He's right here, I know he's right here
Oh boy
Sooo what Imanna do
[Mumbling] Eee I don't like this X2
(scared mumbling) I don't know where he is
AAAAAAH I HATE THIS
ERR I HATE THAT
What I'm gonna to do X2
is Imanna deviate away from the Aurora for just a hot second
because I know that there, are more
changes to the map
than have been for told.
So, I'm going to actually go in a different direction than I've gone before
to try to find some new things
because the- I need the laser cutter to be able to get the Pron.
I have to come back to get the Aurora at some point but right now
I don't have what I need
And, it's obvious to me the Sea Moth fragments are not on the Aurora
so, what I'm going to do is I'm going to deviate- I'm gonna go back
I'm gonna pit stop here real quick
so I can drop off some stuff in exchange.
Uhh, but what I'm gonna do is im going to probably towards the other island.
the uhh-the not quite mountain...
range thing, the "Not Mountain"
the thing that's literally just an underwater mountain
that formed up, because i'm willing to bet that there's something on that second island
that I need-
and if the Sea Moth is there...
Which it might be!
Im trying not to look things up, just because I wanna play this-
ya' know for truesies.
But if it's not there, than, oh well, no big loss i'm still in a new area.
But if there's some resource there, like a diamond that I can get that is useful.
Then hey!
that's not to bad! so we're just gonna find it.
We're gonna play it by ear and we're gonna find it.
hokay!
I have food, I have water, I have a health kit, I have less than ideal batteries...
BUT HEY You know swimming by myself ain't to bad so if my...if my thing is over there...
I believe the mountain range is generally in this direction...so..
Im gonna have to go past -my good buddies-  the giant screaming floating b*stards- ohho there you are!
terrifying as they may be.
I do believe they are key to-my journey
Im out of power on that one...OKAY YOU WOULDN'T HAPPEN TO HAVE ANY BATTERIES WOULD YA?
NOOO?
Alright! have a nice day...
I think I have explored this wreck before
but if I haven't...
im gonna take a quick gander...
Karen: Caution 30 seconds of oxygen remaining
Thank you Karen
woah oh!
oh.
OOOOOOHHHHHH (victory screech)
YEEESSS
YEESS
YAAAAAY!
Karen: 10 seconds of oxygen remain
OH I CAN'T MAKE THAT
CAN I...OH FUCK me...
Oh fuck me
OH
WA-WOAH-WOW
THAT WAS Frickn' close
Thank you eclipse!
hohoholy shit
that was awesome.
okay so what that did...
I now have the plans for the Sea Moth- I do! But then I suddenly realized...
I can't make that! I don't have the Mobile Vehicle Bay
do i...
I...
do NOOOooT
I don't...
*groan of dissapointment*I don't
agggh that's a sack of tits ain't it!
OOOH THAT'S A SACK OF BALONEY!!
OHHH BOOY
DAMMMN IT
okay so I do not have the Mobile Vehicle Bay.
Where the fricka-frack do you get the Mobile Vehicle Bay!
I DON'T FRICKIN-FRACKIN' KNOW
But you know what i'm just gonna keep the course for where I was going...
I believe the mountain range is over this way...
Let's keep plowing forward because frankly- hey! We got the Sea Moth!
And that's not to bad...we don't HAVE have it, but we have can build it-
-ooh
hello!
You are BIG...Oh so you're a big wreck.
Okay so i'm gonna- i'm gonna explore this bad-boy.
Cause there might be something of value in here...
(roars of sandsharks)
yeow-oh fucking fuck-
sh-stop it STop it-STOPIT
whater u?
(attacked by sandsharks)
FUCKING STOP OOW OOW
THAT WAS A BATTERY CHARGER
FUCKING FUCK
Freaking douchebags, I think that was a battery charger
did that say that was-if that was a battery charger I am
In
Golden shape.
I would be soo Happy !
Man those things are just
HANGEGEN around that battery charger
Oh god damn it, ah fuuck, I'll take a bite
[Nearby sandshark growls]
Light stick? That's not what I wanted
Where it go x3
OOH God x5
I'M DANCING IM DANCING I'M DANICING
What's in hereee?
First Aid Kit , yes I need that (sandsharks roaring)
I'm gonna need that, AH FUck.
OW OW OW OW OW OWIE OW OOOW OW (singing ow)
Where the FUCK was it?!
Oh God where the fuck...
(can't talk to frustrated)
It just fucking disappeared are you Kidding ME!
Karen: Caution 30 seconds of oxygen (Mark: God damn it)
OH What are you! Tiger plant, stop
FUCKING STOOP!
Everything wants to kill me so badly
e, everything absolutely want to annihilate my face.
Jesus
This is fucking awful
Karen: Emergency 10 seconds of oxygen
OH MY GOOOOOOOODDDD
(groans) Oh mmmmmaaann I got ta stop that,
that probably doing severe brain damage. (pronounced dabledge)
Man this is the most aggressive
thing that's been in this game.
And I do not appreciate it, why are you all around here?
Stop chasing after me, I don't know what that was
God damn it I couldn't find it again
Alright is there a way in here? In this piece of wreakage?
Something good for me maybe?
Ok, what's in here?
Ooh that sounds bad
It's a dead end! Oh okay.
Eeugh that sounds EEUEHUGH  okay
I'm SORRY
IM SORRY Okay, alright.
Okay then, is that a way in?
Why do I keep getting-
I think- I think my uh, I think my Sea Glider just got damaged
Is that even a thing that can happen?
Oh it seems damaged
Is that what that staticing is?
No.
Oh okay, it was on the Fritz
Alrighty Then.
Everything's back to nooormal now I think.
What is that?
That is definetly a thing.
What are you? [Gasp] MOBILE VEHICLE BAY!
Oh was that the thing that was that I found?
God damn, these sharks.
Is this a light stick? I don't need a light stick, I don't need a light stick I don't need a light stick
FUCKING STOOOPPP
OWWWW
Oh I don't wanna go in there
Karen: Caution 30 seconds of oxygen remaining (background)
I can't go in there,
God damn it, there just fucking everywhere..
but I found a piece of the Mobile Vehicle Bay.
This is not going any faster
Karen: Emergency 10 seconds of oxygen
Oh okay I'm Fucked cause god
damn it.
I do not understand what's happening with my
sea glide, it is very broken and I am gonna die.
Here we go not quite, okay
Holy Shit
WELL there's the island, that wasn't there before..
Oo~kay
(out of breath) wow
what is happening to me (raspy low voice)
What is HAPPENING TO ME (higher pitched)
I don't know (choked up voice)
(laugh/cough) I don't know
I just wanna find the rest of the Mobile Vehicle Bay fragments.
I don't know if I'm gonna be able to find them all.
In TIME
before I run out of air
and I definitely don't wana get trapped going down here
but
Oh Fuck I can't even go in there
but I see another piece.
Fuck
(whispers) How do I get in there?
I don't know
Karen: Warning out oxygen..again
God DAMN IT WHY
UHHH I don't know if I just picked
like uh the world's worst, particular wreck to explore but
I'm in a lot of trouble here and I barely have any time
and I'm out-completely out of batteries.
I can only hope this is going to pay out for me.
'Kay here we go, Bioreactor, nice, I like it
Okay that's one
MOBILE VECHILE BAY I LIKE IT, that's another
plant pot not what I needed.
Not what I need
What is that, is that Mobile Vehicle Bay?
Battery charger, shit not what I needed but it's okay I'll take it.
So I did, I did see battery charger tho-
OHHHHHH YYEESS
YESSS, YES, YES okay that's SOO GOOD
That is SOOO GOOD, OH and another battery charger.
I can just make out this one and then I'm gonna get the F*CK BACK
YEESSS
YYYYYEEEEESSSS
YYEEESS (voice cracking)
Ho man that was so difficult
Oohh My God
Okay we got, the Mobile Vehicle Bay and the battery charger
which are two things that we absolutely did need.
Karen: Emergency 10 seconds of oxyegen
Man I got something in my eye, like right in the end there
it was like, "Yay Victory, okay here's something to stab you in your cornea."
Thank you, I definitely wanted a piece of derbey inside my ocular orifice.
Anyway we got what we needed, I'm gonna head back
I'm gonna build all this stuff and in the episode we are gonna have
a Sea moth and the means with which to finally explore the deep
depth. Yes Bubblebutt is gonna make his grand return or her (quickly adds her)
is a ship I don't think they have gender's, it doesn't matter.
I've got it!
AND EVERYTHING IS GONNA BE OKAY.
Maybe, we, I don't know, maybe 100% maybe
But that's a solid,  I'm going to put a solid Maybe on that one.
I actually do not know, but either way that is all the time I have for this episode.
We made some good progress here like seriously good progress
and we've added a lot of, serious trouble along the way
but I will forgive this game for doing that for me.
It is still being a son of a bitch but you know it's the kind
of son of a bitch you gotta have around for Thanksgiving, so
Thank You Everybody so much for watching. Let me know what you thought
down in the comments below and as always
I will see You in the Next Video, Bye Bye
(Outro)